[Music]
when was the last time you went to a
store and physically bought an item I
find nothing I mean by now I mean I
literally think the last time I bought
something was when I went with d-roc
into that Nike store in a couple
episodes of dailyvee like four months
ago but some mics like I just don't like
[ __ ] like food things I put in my mouth
I bind like gum and sunflower seeds but
I don't buy [ __ ] I recently started
working my own business my question is
right yo yeah way better how are you
we're going let's go cool
painfully introverted I recently started
as a [ __ ] iridescent for somebody to
hustle to face off on everything they
have to just approach a new personal
situation to get a partner that can be
the extrovert being an introvert and
being the back behind the scenes person
is a tremendous strategy and something
that you shouldn't hide from that you
should lean in on but you need a partner
how do I determine if the employee is
the right fit for a culture from the
culture perspective how do I maintain
inspiring works by giving them what they
want
and guilting them into loyalty 5149 for
life
once you get to an entrepreneur starting
its own marketing business in a somewhat
saturated market and limited budget hold
your [ __ ] breath the odds are against
you which is perfect because now we find
out if you're good enough there's no
there's no advice there's just execution
irineu what what did he teach you or
helped to guide you that's really
interesting most influential friend
right
that's good one I would say the most
influential friend I had most
influential friends so I was the most
influential friend to everybody this
literally is like a Chuck Norris
I am a right like influential friend who
was the most influential friend you know
it's really funny it's gonna be such a
big shout-out I really think that my
brother Vijay is the biggest influential
friend I've ever had
because he is somebody I just respect
and their and I love the way he was a
straight shooter I think he made me a
better manager like he he just inspired
me he's 11 years younger than me but my
brother believe it or not I mean I have
great friends growing up but for some
reason they weren't able to really
influence me but Ajay how did you keep
your perspective alive legit [ __ ] hits
the fan
perspective is binary once you realize
that health is the only thing that
matters and the help of the you and the
five to 15 people you care about most
it's just [ __ ] hitting the fan is only
you know when something is wrong there
and that's and that you focus on but
like everything else doesn't matter if
it's possible to create or enhance
desire or ambition for something if so
how or is it you have it or you don't I
don't fully know how to answer this
question my intuition is it has a lot
more to do with you have it where you
don't then people want to admit because
then it feels like we're not in control
but I don't underestimate manifesting
things but then the question becomes is
that the having it received home
chicken-and-egg right gotta create your
story
yeah but then but then you have to
deliver on it or or then it's a [ __ ]
story and me saying I'm going to be like
an NFL quarterback cuff me saying I'm
going to buy the Jets that sell
realistic because I thought I'd be a big
enough businessman so I think there's
some practicality as to come along with
it how to inspire loyalty by providing
loyalty first
too far question what is your person's
personal favorite piece of content
you've ever put out and why and it's
different what piece of content you wish
more people took action on that's super
cool
my favorite piece of content ever put
out was episode 1 of Wine Library
because it was the first one and all I
did was from the second I decided that
it was a good idea I did it like
literally within hours it was in hours
of deciding I want to do a wine show on
YouTube I did it and that's why it's my
favorite because it was me living my
thesis the the piece of content I wish
more people would consume is my podcast
hashtag why talk when you're on a port
mention you know when your genius said
that you knew the internet was going to
be a big thing so you Vanessa heavily in
it what do you think the next big thing
will be ten years the internet was a
unique platform it wasn't some you know
it was like it was so unique you know
that's one of the five to seven biggest
things that have happened to the human
race so I don't know if I'll ever see
anything like that again
maybe maybe virtual reality ecosystem
right so I'm not sure I don't predict I
react how often have you been made aware
that people have been turned off by what
you have to say due to your intensity
and our honesty what is your response to
this kind of perception I'm fully aware
100% of where my response is on the
mirror what I do makes people reflect on
who they actually are and people that
don't like what they're hearing I have
to dig deep and figure out why because
I'm coming from a very good place and
I'm suffocating [ __ ]
I'm also not asking for anything like we
need to we need to have that
conversation one day like I'm not
creating all this stuff for some funnel
to my $1100 eBook
how can an influencer make money besides
product placement by creating a product
or service to sell to the audience that
gives them attention I am an influencer
that has never taken $1 and product
placement but I built a half a billion
dollar valuation agency on my foot
how should I know I like it that's true
so the four hundred million dollar
valuation business on the back of my
purse somewhere
forget about valuation that's just a
bigger number until one hundred fifty
million dollar revenue business how
should one way the differences between
pivoting or throwing in the towel an
idea on an idea or goal versus continue
to plow ahead impossible to answer
at a macro on a micro I'd have to spend
a lot of time and figure it out however
even if I audited it correctly the
person making that decision has to be
ready for one or the other that's the
only way to make that decision who are
the top influencers in business here
technology and I have no idea
and to go back to that it's because I'm
not consuming it so I don't want to put
anybody on without really knowing what
they're about you know whoever it's
bringing you value at the moment
feel free to pivot once you die extract
them to tell you out of that person what
are some of your predictions as to where
social media is heading in the next five
to ten years
higher
how do you get your foot in the door
with a sports agency such as greener
sports by cold emailing and beaming
everybody involved in the
decision-making process PS this will not
work at Vayner sports when I do feel
like college taught you valuable
business tools or do you feel like
majority of your business knowledge Camp
Roger sources I feel like all of my
business knowledge came from other
sources I learned nothing in college
from a business standpoint I learned a
lot about from college from from growing
up as a man standpoint from from a swag
standpoint from a basketball standpoint
from a hip-hop music standpoint zero
business how do you overcome an
uncertainty time is the most finite
resource we all have how do you decide
to spend yours on spenders I spend no
time debating the crippling nature of
the finite resource I spend all my time
just doing and adjusting to what's
happening
so anything practical I can do every day
to stay consistent and motivators one
more time
is there anything practical I can do
every day to stay consistent and
motivated make pretend that your family
died today I'm a 36 year old father and
husband with two little girls I'm
looking to change my career from how
would you go about this when you have
people depending on you Tom it's scary
yeah so the way I would do that is by
auditing my schedule and deploying every
minute that I'm selfish using much for
myself with for escapism watching a game
hanging out with buddies and I would
allocate that towards building the base
of my business online with no caching
risk which aka means producing content
and a personal brand as a leverage point
to the business I wanted to build
because at the end of the day you can't
take the risk of the rent and like the
food and shelter and the clothes that
you need to put on your family's back so
the answer to the question is a hedge
practical hedge
it's called practical hedging you know
you're basically sucking out all the
things that you know you're wasting time
on that isn't binary to building your
business and taking care of your family
everything else is out that's what I did
in a lot of ways outside the Jets I'm
suffocated leisure
this is a weird day all this count I
like trying son you know you said that
if someone were people running tired how
who's really tired
you said that if someone wants to find
their passion they must try new things
how try to start where should I look for
these possible actions YouTube blogs
internships yep
my business is growing should I can tell
you increasing my product portfolio or
focusing on improving marketing and
sales growth how would you monetize a
Facebook fan page the Harnish pump when
he likes an answer he gets fired out
that how would you monetize his Facebook
fan page that is based on a TV show
you can run ads I mean there's there's
pre Facebook go back Facebook now has a
pre-roll and post roll ad product that
they're rolling out you'll be able to
monetize through ads you can do
affiliate marketing and sell t-shirts
and things of that nature for sites that
sell products you can create your own
product and service and sell through
guys when you're done guys
there's kind of like three ways to make
money right you sell services you sell
something right or you sell advertising
the attention it has like there's not
that many ways to make money product
services or attention so you're selling
what do you think of cryptocurrency and
are you planning to invest I have
invested years ago I plan on I plan on
investing more in the future to educate
myself but this is an arena that I
haven't gone deep enough in yet and so I
don't feel comfortable really putting my
links behind it for someone that that
has what might be perceived as a boring
but valuable product or service like
personal like personal personal
insurance how would you recommend that
they develop an audience or produce
content that is interesting by talking
about things around somebody's life and
going through life and not about the
insurance itself so maybe talking about
lifestyle hacks realities creating
content around what it's like to be 30
to 80 years old not about the insurance
themself bringing value in other areas
you know like health and wellness or or
vacation advice using content as a
gateway drug to the insurance product
around the psychographics of the
how much of your effort yes yes and then
on yeah so it means it's an important
point note sometimes I keep spoke to the
best tell a story around the wheel how
much of your effort or online presence
are you going to shift to audio the next
12-24 was one more time how much of your
time and online presence will you shift
to audio the next well between schools
okay how much of your effort and online
presence are you shift to audio a
substantial amount but it won't be
shifting it will be in addition to when
I do things if I'm rolling it doesn't
come at the expense of something it's
added on to something when do you go to
sleep do you try to go to sleep at 6:00
time every time every day or is it most
often beyond your control my normal is
twelve six my Russian is really my
Russian is I understand everything I
have a heavy American accent when I
speak it I can't read or write if you're
just starting on social you fire with
one channel or use all guns
get the reverse engineer yourself all
guns is always better but you may not be
capable of that and then you want to go
with one channel so that's a very
personal question comes down to energy
and desire because no I don't talk
enough about desire I've such a li use
ambition right how do you seen some ways
right there's similar ish
call me here listen I think that your
ambition would have to match your desire
what is design I decide I want I feel
like I both of them sound like I wanna
like your dreams or like what's your
ambition yeah but your ambitions the
matter desire chronic condition I don't
know whatever it is goodbye
time to apply the Jets but my ambition
is to buy the Jets I feeling that you
were doing a bad job Tyler
describing difference yeah terrible but
I just know I have more of it than all
of you
alright the people you say horrible
times are coming from circa mortar
retail the identity Destin and how a
small brick and mortar firm counteract
this yes by compelling their online
presence I just function how fashion
beauty blog and YouTube channel one of
the best strategies for growth because
this is a saturated market quality
content continuity business development
with people that have audiences to bring
you awareness rinse and repeat
what do you think about native
advertising in general and about
platforms like tabouleh native
advertising as its defined today is
diminishing in its value but native
advertising is phenomenal it means
you're integrating into content in a
more seamless way than disrupting the
cadence of the reader listener or
watcher why Apple and not answering um
for me Apple was just out first I don't
know if it was out first for look in
real life but like I just got on the
iPhone earlier than Android and just I'm
like many people creature of habit and
have been happy with my experience Plus
app culture really solidified it because
the apps that I wanted were always
available on Apple first if you
accidentally stumbled upon enough money
to buy the Jets today would you and if
so what would you set your sights on
next yes Super Bowls coming to Australia
because yes November he chose to come
what's your taking quality over quantity
when it comes to content or product
variety Oh
am i right about a stud November right
okay Berber seventh and ninth thought so
an anchor in the news experience with
audio / podcast and the opportunity for
creators over the last 48 72 hours I've
heard a ton about it and my social but
I've been so busy promoting playing the
apps and running vaynermedia I haven't
had a chance to look I look good and
next week I need somebody to fit
actually I need everybody to figure that
[ __ ] out sorry did you bring that up
gosh I wish I'd use with the business I
want to start already exist do it better
like every [ __ ] business on earth you
today one of the habits are principles
you focus almost right now um work ethic
listening um when's your next book
coming out January 2018
Todd is looking up ambition party money
trustus clutching desires in the
definition of ambition so desires
wanting something to happen the ambition
is pretty much a framework of desiring
plus it's solution okay desires wanting
something to happen ambitious the desire
plus the execution tell more I didn't
get yourself out of a funk perspective
cool yeah good
[Music]
you
[Music]